what up space fam golden here from anime
upper and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story we
got Zoro versus mihawk huge action huge
reveals the mystery of Stussy revealed
an insane unexpected appearance and much
more so make sure to stay tuned for this
epic chapter trailer parking with it and
smash that like button with no mercy if
you enjoyed these weekly review videos
and want to keep them coming make this
the video you joined the nakama if you
haven't already by subscribing and
ringing that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future videos last week over 54 of you
watching weren't subscribed so let's try
to get that number down to at least 50
percent this time and now without
further Ado let's jump into It spoilers
and all this chapter is called Miss
Buckingham Stussy and of course it's
called that because we'll get to figure
out what's going on after that insane
Cliffhanger last chapter where Stussy
took out Kaku before aiming her sights
on fellow cp0 member Luchi I usually
don't mention cover stories but this one
is too good and perfect we see a flash
back to back up on getting the ibel
Peace Prize so like our Nobel Peace
Prize pretty much for developing the GP
flower a flower that blooms in gunpowder
it goes well with what we've learned
about vegapunk which is that he wants
Peace and Freedom but it's also just
hilarious seeing how shocked the dudes
and tanks look as they see their
Battlefield turn into a beautiful Garden
of Flowers it's just so Oda and I love
it but back to luchi's reaction to
stussy's betrayal very serious stuff
here Kaku is on the ground passed out
and Luchi is sweating clearly confused
he says it's a bitter pill to swallow
while Stussy looks calm and even Smiles
she's really fast too Luchi goes for the
kill but she uses an after image
technique to avoid the attack then we
get a great scene she uses her lipstick
which actually contains seastone to
weaken Luchi before also sucking his
blood she explains that she knows how
strong they are so it would be stupid to
fight them fair and square and I like to
see characters like that occasionally
who don't want to win fair and square
they'll do whatever is necessary to win
anyways Luchi collapses and so Stussy
just dealt with two strong cp0 agents
all by herself but the big question is
why and maybe she didn't touch the CSUN
herself but since she's a clone it is
possible that her powers aren't a real
devil fruit so she could even be
unaffected by sea Stone which would give
her a big leg up compared to devil fruit
users especially when she has access to
Sea Stone this is also possible because
we even saw how the seraphims have fruit
powers without actually having consumed
the fruits the favorite theory in the
comment section last week though was
definitely that Stussy had a mythical
succubus fruit anyways for now we gotta
see why she did that Zorro and Brooke
are similarly confused Stussy then calls
the vegapunks and lets them know that
she put the two to sleep so she was on
vegapunk's side which makes sense since
she was as a clone created by vegapunk
that punk explains that she beat Luchi
because she took him by surprise and
that her loyalty was kept a secret even
after she spent 20 years as one of their
agents on a side note I love it when
characters can hide their true
Allegiance for so long even if it was a
bit less impactful here just because we
haven't gotten a lot of Stussy time it's
funny when vegapunk points out that it
wasn't his intention to have a mole in
the intelligence Branch but that's just
how it turned out so yeah things are
looking really good for our side one
might even say too good so you gotta be
expecting a kind of reversal Fortune
soon for now those Stussy comments that
she can't override the seraphims because
she's the same level of authority as
Luchi I feel like that could have gone
either way like a person of the same
level could have had that power but in
this case it is more interesting for the
story if she doesn't and they have to
hold off the seraphims until the
vegapunks arrive and I'm glad she didn't
have the power because it leads to
something I've been talking about and
waiting for for a while now but more on
that in a bit we see shots of the
seraphims like little boa firing shots
and the Vega punks trying to get there
fast to override them with their higher
authority Zoro and Brooke are running at
first as they notice the similarities of
the seraphims to people they know and it
appears like Zoro even comments on how
the jinbei one is especially familiar I
also love how the seraphims just keep
blowing holes into the walls and Lilith
just uses them to get out faster it's
perfect she gets out and she's about to
give the orders but the mihawk seraphim
is so fast he's about to attack before
she can even get it out luckily and this
is what I've been waiting for Zorro
engages in combat with the mihawk
seraphim like I said I think this battle
will be a great one to have before Zoro
actually takes on the real mihawk so
they clash and you actually see what
looks like sweat on the face of the
mihawk seraphim Zorro is so cool man he
just Smiles saying on closer inspection
you're not the same you actually have a
spark of humanity still not only is it
funny because he's saying that the
pacifista has a spark of humanity still
but it's even funnier because the
implication here is that the pacifista
actually has more Humanity than mihawk
an actual human as far as we know love
this interaction and it definitely
implies Lil mihawk is far from mihawk
level at least for now but it was said
before that they are growing like humans
so you never know what their potential
is as Zoro clashes with the seraphim
Sanji comes and saves Edison from a
little gym Bay attack so that Edison can
actually deliver his order and the
seraphims finally stop and things seem
right with the world again and our guys
are in an amazing position the seraphims
are under control Celestia is helping
them and luchin Kaku are out they
literally have no conscious enemies on
the island as far as we know for the
moment it's also noteworthy that Luchi
and Kaku have been bound with sea Stone
so they should be powerless even when
they wake up and to make matters even
better Stussy is asked to come with them
by vegapunk and she agrees I can see
Sanji being happy about this but usop
hilariously points out that vegapunk
can't just keep adding people and it's
true vagapunk just keeps adding people
on the ship satellite or clone like he's
the captain himself but then again you
can't expect mad scientists to be
socially calibrated in the meantime we
get a shot of Luffy just to remind us he
is doing something and he's still just
looking for Bonnie and vegapunk it's a
situation you'd definitely expect to see
Zoro in meaning lost while the action is
going on it is cool how the immediate
problems were solved though without
Luffy even needing to be be there I will
say though as I mentioned things are too
good now and it's unlikely to stay this
smooth especially with kizuru being on
the way and that is actually addressed
in a big way soon but first we're told
by the narrator that vegapunk's main
body Stella has vanished we last saw him
with Bonnie about to touch what looked
like Kuma's memories but we'll hopefully
figure out what's happening with that in
the next chapter we need that Kuma
flashback then as if we didn't have
enough crazy things going on around the
world we then jump to Sphinx which
you'll remember is whitebeard's Hometown
and the place that was under his
protection Marco was sort of overseeing
it before he went to wano we got the
little kids explaining the situation to
Marco the Marines came and they were in
trouble the Marines were looking for
whitebeard's Treasure just like Pirates
I mean it makes sense Whitebeard was a
very famous pirate and you'd think he
had a bunch of treasure the Marine even
threatens to shoot them showing once
again that the Marines can be just as
bad or in many cases worse than Pirates
what side you're on is Trivial compared
to one's individual character it's
pointed out that the Marine don't treat
the helpless people of the island like
humans simply because they can't pay the
government tax it's crazy that there
were so many consequences to Marco just
leaving for a little bit the island
definitely needs a protector luckily as
the granny is about to be shot in the
flashback the Marines are taken out by
former warlord Weevil self-proclaimed
son of Whitebeard and I'm starting to
like this dude I gotta say whether he is
the true son or not and that mustache
definitely looks like he is I like how
seriously he takes his role as the sun
he tells all the Marines to stay away
from his Poppy's home it's actually
quite wholesome I gotta say and if
you're wondering yes it's still ironic
that Whitebeard treated everyone like
his son except potentially his actual
son we see the power of Weevil though
all the Marines run crying from him I
love seeing how the former Warlords
continue to have such a huge impact on
world events and I'm hoping most of them
just join cross Guild because I want
that organization to be as big as
possible Weevil is called a bona fide
monster the Marine means a request
immediate assistance from the world
government a kid explains that we will
save the day if he hadn't shown up they
and the village would be toast it's very
fitting that whitebeard's son would save
his treasured Village from destruction
it's definitely nice to see how much
Weeble Works to be recognized as
whitebeard's son when there are people
like Ace who try to distance themselves
from their true father even Marco calls
Weevil a hero and yes I think like Marco
I'm a Weeble fan too now smash that like
button if you are too then we get
something big former member of The
Rock's Pirates Miss buckin AKA
Buckingham Stussy the real one appears
she is as we know weevil's Mom and she
is crying like you'd expect from a mom
no matter how legendary her reputation
it's funny too how she's labeled as a
self-proclaimed scientist and also as
mad's resident freeloader looks like
self-proclamations definitely run in
this family anyways she explains the
Admiral green bull finally actually did
something and he appeared helping to
capture we Stussy wants Marco to help
get her son back and also to Fork over
new Gate's inheritance so a bit of
Comedy there with the inheritance but in
all honesty this is fascinating stuff
now that we know what Stussy probably
looked like before from her clone it's
not that difficult to believe that
Whitebeard and her developed a
relationship while being on The Rock's
ship like big mom Stussy looked good
back in the day and it's not hard to
picture a man getting seduced by her and
now we might actually have Marco
motivated to go save the son of
Whitebeard and even if he's not the real
son he acts so much like a son would
better in some cases so perhaps that's
enough to get Marco on board to help
especially considering how much the real
white beard meant to him and so we have
yet another crazy Side Story happening
along with all of the others happening
right now and I gotta say it's actually
sad seeing mom Stussy cry after Weeble
as he screams mama from the ship she
cries before Marcos saying he was sent
to prison for protecting his father's
Village she comments don't you think our
boy has a noble soul and Marco's says
well he appreciates them protecting the
place at least she can hear in his tone
and from his words that Marco still
doubts that Weevil is whitebeard's
actual son so Stussy says she knows
someone who can prove it vegapunk now
there has to be something there whether
it's legit his son or a partial clone of
Whitebeard remains to be seen but we
can't deny that there does seem to be
something to it the mustache doesn't lie
people and it's super hype that we might
have Marco reuniting with Luffy and crew
because of this after all they have
vegapunk and Stussy just mentioned
wanting to see vegapunk with Marco as if
that wasn't enough for one chapter we
jump to kizero the OG Admiral himself
it's revealed that one of the five
Elders is on the ship with him he met
Vega Punk before and thinks what's
happening now is truly a shame we're
told one of the big wigs finally makes a
move I myself said it would be hard to
picture an elder coming to the
battlefield but I'll be the first to say
it I was wrong oh it is clearly doing
just that and although I still don't
expect much strength from the Elder this
is significant because he has the
authority to bring the seraphims back
over to the Marine side now we have
potentially kizaru and the seraphims
being set up versus the straw hats it's
definitely a fight worth watching and
thus despite the fact that it was cut
short it seems like we'll get to see
Zoro versus LOL mihawk continue soon
enough and since the Warlords and the
seraphims are so hype and relevant right
now you definitely don't want to miss
our video on all of the Warlords
explained link on screen and in the
description that not only covers
everything you need to know about all of
the Warlords but goes into the seraphims
as well